[SPEAKER_01]: So, you and Owen walking down the docks into the marketplace.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen basically is talking to one merchant after another.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically passing by, asking for wares.
[SPEAKER_01]: Normal stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically the two of you spend 20 minutes just kind of walking down the wharf.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's pointing to things, showing where things are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just kind of chatting with you about certain stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is making deals as you go and saying, oh yeah, we'll pick that up later.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll pick that up later.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk up to a new wharf, kind of a little dock, and he says, hey, look at that boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you like that boat?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like another sloop, very much like the one that you're on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you think of her?
[SPEAKER_01]: She's nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Isn't she?
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the one I had for Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is Tyrus' new boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Really?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Was it pre-established that you bought Tyrus a new boat?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, he's going to have to work for me for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I needed two crews to be able to bring it in.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the deal, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to go check her out?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, shouldn't we wait for Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, shouldn't we wait for the crew?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, yeah, we can wait for the crew, but I mean, it's right here, right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've got to think about getting the hold in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on, let's go check her out.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you guys go and jump on board.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He starts walking towards the cabin.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says things like, I have a friend of mine watching it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go in and see them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He walks to the door and knocks and goes,
[SPEAKER_01]: Taurus, are you there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Then you hear a voice come out of the back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen, is that you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Have you returned?
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen goes, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want you to meet a friend of mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: He opens the door into the cabin and starts walking back there.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see a form in the back and you guys kind of walk back into the area and goes, I've got a bottle.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen Black lifts up one of those black things of rum from Portoli.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your favorite.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is my friend Folsom.
[SPEAKER_01]: He walks in.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, it's pretty dark in here, Taurus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why don't you light the lantern?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you come into the cabin?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a perception check, insight check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight plus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk in, in the darkness, the form you can't quite make out.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Owen goes, here, take a seat.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll let a lantern.
[SPEAKER_01]: He shuts the door.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear the striking of a match and the lantern gets lit, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And the form across the table reaches out and grabs the bottle as Owen turns the thing around.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you realize this dude is a soul.
[SPEAKER_01]: He sits down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen sits next to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you realize that you're in a very small cabin
[SPEAKER_01]: With two very large men.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of them who's obviously from Portoli and the other one's from, well, it's Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Owen looks at this guy, Tyrus, and goes, Folsom was asking me some questions today.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's very interested in that artifact Kane totally has.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Tyrius goes, Oh, is he?
[SPEAKER_01]: What would you like to know about it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh... Well...
[SPEAKER_00]: I was just...
[SPEAKER_00]: Curious about, uh...
[SPEAKER_00]: Seems pretty powerful.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seems very, uh...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: It just seems very, very important.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was wondering if it was, how long it's been around for, you think?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, well, the stone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrius looks at Owen and goes, Hundreds of years, I imagine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rumor is, the Lich Azorak made it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can't totally learn about it from
[SPEAKER_01]: This necromancer in the swamp we dealt with.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why so interested?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, it's just rumors and tales.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what Owen said.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just, I'm a...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm a sucker for a good story.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Many people are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen kind of puts his hands on the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: He says, Folsom here is a good friend of my cousin Merrick.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrius goes, oh really?
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsom goes, I mean not Folsom, Owen Black says, Merrick's in town with two other men.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know how much longer they're going to be alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Didn't want Folsom to suffer the same fate as the minis with.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry Folsom.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do feel bad about Tyrius.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was a good friend.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I wanted to make sure you didn't get hurt, seeing as you're so young and all.
[SPEAKER_00]: I appreciate that, Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus is a good friend of mine.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a shame.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, you're going to be the prisoner of Cain totally now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Until all of this blows over.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean, business is business.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm being paid very well.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think Keoland totally would find you entertaining.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have a good voice and you're young and I think you know some things that you might be interested in hearing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, you got it right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am entertaining.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't know how to put on a good show.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then Toli reaches down and picks the manacles up off the floor and puts them on the table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Manacles are like cuffs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just Owen and me and him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh-huh.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could put those on.
[SPEAKER_01]: It saved me beating you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen takes the rum.
[SPEAKER_01]: Puts down.
[SPEAKER_01]: A shot.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, first a drink, and he pours a shot of the black liquid into the cup.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I take it, and I raise it up, and I say, am I facing him?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're facing both of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're like here, the table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're here.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Toli is across the table and Owen Black is right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the lanterns on the table?
[SPEAKER_01]: Lanterns on the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where's the bottle?
[SPEAKER_01]: Bottles on the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: The glass is right there with the manacles.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: I uh...
[SPEAKER_00]: I say... Well... Before...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm put into cuffs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I have a better drink than that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I don't want a glass, I want a swig.
[SPEAKER_01]: Asul pulls a knife out and puts it on the table and he's like, We're being friendly here, not kind.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm just wanting a drink before I...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Drink it.
[SPEAKER_00]: My tolerance is high.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you'll find this to be quite a strong drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can have as much of this as you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it filled pretty high?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: How big, like just shot glass?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just shot glass.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: I...
[SPEAKER_00]: I grab the drink.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much proof does it have?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it like flammable?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a rum drink.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I'm sure that there is going to be flames with it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now the lantern is not an open flame.
[SPEAKER_00]: Will I pick up the shot?
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: I raise it up, and I say to the legend, Owen Blackwell, or Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_00]: I take the shot, and I shoot it in his eye.
[SPEAKER_01]: In Owen's eye?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you go like that, roll a 20, and see what that's like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus, what would that be?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen plus your dex.
[SPEAKER_00]: My dex bonus?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus two, so twenty-one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-one.
[SPEAKER_01]: The stuff splashes in his eye, and I assume you're trying to blind him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: This does one point of damage to Owen Black, because it's not anything, but he's going to have to make a saving throw to see if he's blinded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Five.
[SPEAKER_01]: It goes right in his face.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a one-dice six to see how many rounds he's going to be blinded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two rounds.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have two rounds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically jumps up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll an ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's thirteen?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is what the Toli guy gets.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven, eight, nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: You win.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you gonna do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I...
[SPEAKER_00]: I pull out my rapier.
[SPEAKER_00]: Before I do that, I'm going to look at...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm shaking a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm excited.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's been a while.
[SPEAKER_00]: I use...
[SPEAKER_00]: Damn, it's an action.
[SPEAKER_00]: Never mind then.
[SPEAKER_01]: I pull out my rapier.
[SPEAKER_01]: You stand up and pull out your rapier.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I try to thrust it into the... Do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Rapiers are pretty long, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you could attack that guy from across the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could also attack Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I don't want to attack Owen.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to attack him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you attack him across the table.
[SPEAKER_01]: You thrust, roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fifteen plus, is it attack bonus?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you get a plus... Five, so twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: One die eight plus three.
[SPEAKER_01]: One die, yeah, that's a one die six you have there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you're right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll use this one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five plus three, so eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you stab him.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And do you want to move?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to move behind...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, the question is, do you want to take these guys out, or do you want to try and get away?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to... Because you could go one, two, three... Did they lock the door?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um... Is there a key?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will, yeah, move to the door then.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can go one, two, open the door, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, and like back out with your rapier out, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you move to here with the rapier out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, can I...
[SPEAKER_00]: It's dark, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, if I walk outside, can't see anything really?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I mean, you'll have the moon and everything, so they'll see you if you run away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I... One, two, three... Is this like...
[SPEAKER_01]: If you wanted to, what you could do actually is use another five moons to shut the door and try and hold the door shut.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't got the strength of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was going to try to hide right here so when they came out I could see them.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a thing like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's really no place to hide.
[SPEAKER_00]: I figured.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I will jump, I will just start running back to the...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can use your bonus action to run another six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you run out onto the deck.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear the door open behind you, and you hear Owen Black yelling, stop him!
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy runs to here, pulling out his knife.
[SPEAKER_01]: Rolling ish.
[SPEAKER_00]: 20 plus 2.
[SPEAKER_01]: 22.
[SPEAKER_00]: 22.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to try and get away?
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to first see, do you know if Vicious Mockery is, is that an action or a bonus action?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is a bonus action?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am going to have my rapier at him, look at him, have my rapier looking at him, and I want to move six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Towards the dock.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just grabbing my beer and my cake.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually I'm gonna drink the tank.
[SPEAKER_00]: Super duper cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to... and so am I on the dock now?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you can be on the dock if you go that way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so, and I will still be seeing him if I'm right here, and I can use Vicious Mockery on him from there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I'm gonna run this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: As my bonus action, I'm gonna yell at him with Vicious Mockery.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And say...
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's his saving throw.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go ahead and do your mockery.
[SPEAKER_00]: I hope that...
[SPEAKER_00]: I hope the piercing of my rapier stings more than the shot of the black rum would have.
[SPEAKER_01]: He does not make it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You do one die four of damage plus what else?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh...
[SPEAKER_00]: Because you have sarcasm.
[SPEAKER_00]: If Vicious Mockery is plus one Charisma, add Charisma bonus to damage of your Vicious Mockery.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Charisma bonus, since I have Charisma bonus just here, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's plus five now.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's plus five.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's one die four plus five.
[SPEAKER_00]: One die four plus five.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will use this one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ooh!
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, it stings.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a 9 point damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you've already done 8.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's taking 17 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's like, ugh!
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of falls backward.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to use your action to run down the pier?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to use my action to... maybe want to cast something really quick.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've already done a cantrip.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can only cast one spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he has disadvantage with whatever he does.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I guess I'll just keep running.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you run another 30 feet down the docks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you get out of there and you run off, heading back, hopefully.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to just run into the city or run down the pier?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to go to the... Now here's the situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Think of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You heard Owen say that your friends were probably going to be killed, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And that he was just saving you.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was going to be...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, giving you decaying totally.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I'm frantic, in that time, I should just run back to the bar, but then not enter and maybe... Like, does the bar have, like, windows and such?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, it's, like, open all over the place.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's got a roof.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's pretty much what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I will...
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess I will start running back to there, and then once I start to get close, mind myself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Try to straighten up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, try to be in the crowd and kind of look in there to make sure that I'm not running into seeing my friends dead or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Danger.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you make your way back up the docks, going back to the chart room.
[SPEAKER_01]: And as you approach it, you begin to slow up.